a
[Música]
y
brasilia ha superado las 160.000 muertes
por el cob y 19 y está en este momento
prácticamente sin ninguna medida de
confinamiento aquí está casi todo
permitido ir a la playa a un centro
comercial o incluso a un espectáculo de
samba bien es cierto que a lo largo de
las últimas semanas las cifras diarias
de muertes por el coronavirus han ido
bajando de forma constante hoy la media
diaria de 400 muertos pero brasil sigue
teniendo uno de los peores datos del
mundo es el segundo en número de muertos
y se queda solo por detrás de los eeuu
además los mayores institutos de
investigación advierten de que esos
datos no son reales que no se está
registrando todo lo que habría que
registrar y que probablemente habrá que
multiplicar las cifras oficiales por
seis además brasil probablemente no va a
poderse liberar de una segunda ola de
contagios parecida a la que está
obligando a muchos países de europa a
endurecer las medidas de confinamiento
[Música]
pero obtuve el triste galardón del país
con la mayor mortalidad del mundo por el
kobe 19 esta nación andina con más de 32
millones de habitantes registra a más de
34 mil fallecidos por coronavirus con
más de 100 muertos por cada 100.000
habitantes conforme a estadísticas
oficiales reunidas por la universidad
johns hopkins eeuu se posiciona este
país en la cima de la escalafón mundial
de excesos diversos expertos reconocen
que el gobierno peruano despliegue
importantes esfuerzos por atender la
crisis sanitaria y afirman que también
lo hace por presentar las cifras
denuncian en base a registros del
sistema nacional de defunciones que en
total han muerto durante la pandemia más
de 79 mil peruanos sin embargo el
presidente martín vizcarra afirma que
las curvas de excesos de mortalidad así
como de contagios y hospitalización se
encuentran en un descenso continuo desde
hace más de dos meses el mandatario
pidió a la población no bajar la guardia
y continuar con las medidas de
precaución para evitar los contagios
[Música]
en lo que va de la crisis sanitaria
bolivia registra más de 8 mil 700
fallecidos por kobe 19 un número que
podría ser pequeño para otros países en
bolivia tiene un significado muy grande
pues este país está entre las naciones
de más altos índices de letalidad en el
mundo en el caso de américa latina
bolivia ocupa el segundo lugar con 70
fallecidos por cada 100.000 habitantes
sólo superado por perú y muy cerca de
los datos de brasil sin embargo debo
comentarles que estudios independientes
aseguran que en bolivia se han producido
más de 20.000 muertos por encima de la
media nacional en relación a años
anteriores lo que habla de que la tasa
de letalidad podría ser muchísimo más
alta por otro lado la pandemia está
prácticamente controlada en el país sin
embargo autoridades temen que se
produzca un rebrote próximamente porque
han existido manifestaciones de protesta
espejos electorales y se han realizado
las elecciones del 18 de octubre todo
esto podría pasarle una factura
sanitaria al país
[Música]